what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alice Hokkien we are now
going to be talking about the purpose of
startups we have dr. Tina Russo vagina
so much so hi Tina hey thank you so much
for coming on thank you for having me
we're super pumped for this episode for
those who don't know Tina's background
she's the founder of Montesa which is a
matchmaking application that allows
people to find the right expert at the
right time at work she's also the author
of big heart ventures which is about the
purpose of startups especially in the
next age of technology you can find the
links in the bio below demand test comm
Tina Russo Viacom also big heart book
calm and her LinkedIn and Instagram
profiles Tina let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guests what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world the direction
of our world well as a tech startup
founder when I'm thinking about our
world I always think about technology
and about entrepreneurship and what we
can see is that technology is become is
converging with all the other systems
that we have installed with our societal
system with our economical system with
even with our bio systems and what this
does is that the efficiency of
technology is becoming omnipresent to
all other systems we are also about for
this to redefine the way we work the way
we live with each other and also
individually and this is a time that I
perceive as a time of transition and
this is the reason why I have written
the book and why I'm really thinking
about the purpose of everything I do
more because I believe that the
efficiency of technology is changing its
effect and
it's important to gain consciousness
back for this reason so we have this
technology that is being democratized
across the planets and abling creativity
it's also somewhat in a sense we're
still spiritually or ethically or
emotionally in kindergarten in some ways
we don't know how to be really good
stewards of the planet yet we still
commit acts of violence over resources
or religious discrepancies or land or
recently all type of stuff discrepancies
so how do we how do we let how do we and
how do we go forth with technology being
democratized and enabling all these
things while we're not really still
spiritually that advanced yet hmm
well I don't know if if an even end
state like this is possible at all what
is specifically interesting about what's
going on right now is that technology
has always been the domain of experts
and specialists of people that had a lot
of boundaries to overcome to use it
think about the installation of a
railway system you have authorities to
grant permissions you have physical
circumstances to overcome to build a
railway system in a country with
information technology and the way how
it democratized itself technology became
accessible for everyone for us for
everyone so also for ordinary people and
the boundaries to use it became really
low so even now for example artificial
intelligence is available as a service
everyone can say I everything so this is
the reason why we need more
consciousness about this but I'm not
sure if an end state where we are fully
conscious spiritually or however is
possible
why don't you think it's possible at all
because technological progress has
always been moving society forward and
improving our lives and if you look back
and compare just ten years backwards 20
years backwards hundred year backwards
we're really well off so we live better
healthier longer than ever before
tendency rising exponentially rising so
I think that technology is you know an
important component empowering humanity
and part of us yeah likewise I see it
that way as well
at the same time I see the desperate
need for us to spiritually actualize and
re commune back with creation or the
divine or source or God and it just
seems as though human has forgotten
source and that we're off playing with
godlike technologies while we're
spiritually in kindergarten and previous
civilizations have collapsed because
they've been doing exactly that
and so our wisdom race that we're in to
raise consciousness fast enough to be
able to deal with the democratized
technologies I think is one of the most
important things that were currently
experiencing mm-hmm yeah go ahead and
maybe it's not something that's lost
because we have in our bodies we have
the ability to sense the right things
the wrong things so we have actually the
biologically we are all set to do this
and I personally believe I'm a huge fan
of technology I personally believe that
it is revealing us to have more time to
find more ways to connect to ourselves
for example just a beautiful photography
of nature is found to reinforce the same
chemical reactions in the body as if we
would be out there seeing it
and experiencing this feeling of ohm is
found to make us better for a certain
period of time so having the technology
to make a lot of beautiful pictures
automatically makes us better and more
connected and yeah yeah there's lots of
aspects of technology that as they
become democratized they can help us
become more spiritually connected and
aware so that's definitely something
that will help you know who were you
growing up you grew up in Bulgaria yes
what was that like growing up there and
you know who were you how did you get
interested in what you care about one
day well I grew up in the 80s in
Bulgaria and I love saying that I was
born at the same time as the internet
but in Eastern Europe and it was a time
of transition from communism to
democracy and a time of constant change
it was actually similar similar to what
we experience now in Western Europe with
digital transformation and
transformation of society and you know
gaining back consciousness because every
transition is connected with a lot of
insecurities in people and also with a
lot of opportunity so I I sometimes I
feel that I am back in the past today
and Bulgaria in this time was a really
interesting place to live because it was
a place of yeah constant change so one
day one day we everyone was forbidden to
go to church on the next day everyone
was allowed and had to go to church even
when the one day we had to wear a
uniform to school on just literally or
the next day no uniforms were needed so
it was like constant change and I think
that this is one of the reasons why I
grew up with this sense of purpose
because you know when everything around
you is constantly changing you either
give up because there
is nothing you can do about it right or
you develop something on the inside that
you can hold yourself to so that there
is this one at least one sustainable
thing in your life
mmm so you found yourself early finding
some sort of a deeper meaning or purpose
and then going forth yeah I don't I
don't know purpose but for me it is more
like this integrity so okay everyone is
constantly changing I have to take care
of Who I am myself it was the lack of
orientation according to the external
environment and then when did you end up
deciding that you wanted to do
innovation management figuring all of
this out yeah well I studied computer
science I came after high school I went
to Germany and I studied computer
science and journalism then I joined a
large tech company and I realized that
the way I had studied did not show did
not prepare me to understand what the
technology that we were producing in the
company was used for and I wanted to you
to know this and went back to to do an
MBA and from the from the MBA I started
the company and the company led me to to
the innovation management so it was
really a messy process finding this yeah
what was the deal when you were when
you're growing up what was the deal with
the indecision with with like the school
or the governance with the different
rules are like why was it one day like
this the next day like that well because
because of the transition communism to
democracy at in one day of the year
and of my life suddenly going to church
became allowed when the communist regime
failed and
it was a single day transition yes but
also the people yes so every it's
difficult for me to talk about this in
in foreign language because I have never
done so but when you have there is in
ethics there is this term of natural law
so when you have a natural law for
example forbidding people to believe
this is a natural law that cannot be
sustained so there there you have
different types of coping mechanisms
with it some people become cynical some
people cope on the outsider list and
some people just play games and as a
child you are children are very
sensitive against all this so you are
precepting all that so it's period of
constant change means that in the one
day you talk with a person that tells
you that everything that's going on has
a reason on the other day you speak with
somebody that is cynical about it so you
don't have external orientation it's a
difficult subject I believe yeah well
especially if that if it's one day it's
like everything has a reason and it's
meaningful and the other day it's like
nihilism yeah yeah but you know we don't
need to get very political but it's also
the same in some medium today too and
this is frightening young people are not
frightening them but just pushing them
back from consuming media this okay the
one day and the other day are not
connected there is no common purpose
combining the the effort of of politics
or initiatives or whatever there is just
this okay whatever makes me successful
yet this subject is one that is there's
times of transitions that have happened
around the world for different cultures
transitioning maybe towards a more one
could say a more spiritually conducive
or a more conducive social fabric to
unleashing people's gifts and so that's
ideally where I want to see things move
in the direction that its enables people
to bring their gifts completely forth
and not in a way that you know that
squelches people's gifts and doesn't
give them the ability to shine hmm and
whatever that fabric looks like I don't
think it looks like what we see with
echo chambers and tribalism and
cognitive ease and the destructive
tendencies of war and fighting over
resources it's we're so spiritually in
kindergarten it's so hard to it's I'm
grateful that at least some places of
transition to what seems to be more
conducive yeah I have an interesting
thought about this yes seriously yes
[Music]
you have a thought about how birds fly
in a common direction so they don't talk
to each other they just know where to
fly kind of like swarm mentality yes and
then there is this evolution of all
animals that learn from all previous
species before them a certain behavior
and I have happened wondering why is
this not so with people because we are
born and then every single baby grows up
to learn in their own speed without
inducing the behavioral evolution of all
the other humans before that and I just
think that it might be that the human
life is just too short for this to
happen because you say we're spiritually
very early on and in the kindergarten
maybe we just don't have enough time to
reach the critical mass for this
inflection point and this is the
interesting thought I will I wanted to
share is maybe this is something that
technology is going to help us with
because we are increasing longevity and
life expectation with technology so
maybe it will become possible through
that to live long enough to go to the
next step so that we also evolve yeah
everything is possible so I'm extremely
open to to that and it also is a big
most pressing issue of our time to
figure out how to globally collaborate
on the future trajectory of the entire
species so hopefully we can do it
everyone hopefully we can do it I have
faith in us now how did you go from
doing your PhD into big heart ventures
into doing your authorship yeah well it
it was very easy so right after my MBA I
started my company because I had turned
mother and for the first time in my life
I had a problem I couldn't go to the gym
and it was 2009 and rapid internet had a
right to Europe and I just had this idea
oh if I can't go maybe it can come to me
like a little bit like the Mohammed in
the mountain and I came up with the idea
of the first online gym I had the
company for four years it was successful
and I became mother for the second time
and it started to get really difficult
to be to be in both froze and hear about
consciousness there are a lot of people
that think they they have to do this and
then they have to do that and I am most
always or I have always asked myself the
question why do you do the things that
you do and being in front of this
dilemma I did something quite I believe
I took it quite a unique decision I
decided to step back from a successful
company to take care of my kids because
I knew I am the only one that can do
this job and I knew that everything else
can wait so stepping back from an
interesting very fulfilling life as a
start-up founder I found myself having a
lot of energy so I didn't want to travel
a lot but I still wanted to work and do
and this is how I came to decide I
decided to do the PhD in innovation
management from then on I started
teaching I started working in big
companies on startup programs creating
acceleration problems creating ways for
young startup companies to cooperate
with big departments of corporations and
yet it has never been as fulfilling as
the startup was so I was asking myself
the question of hey what am i doing am I
the right person to do this aren't they
hundreds of thousands of others
innovation manager
that can do this job well what is my
unique you know qualification to do this
and I couldn't answer this question for
myself because my unique qualification
was somewhere else and it was definitely
as a as a founder in the in the creative
problem-solving space and one day it was
somewhere in between the one startup and
the other somewhere in between of those
five years working in innovation
management I had this idea of big heart
ventures I didn't know what it is but I
just I just stopped and contemplated
this expression for several years and
which time it started to occur to me
what what it is and I started playing
around with I I registered the trademark
because I did a lot of tests so you can
find all sorts of flyers I gave
workshops on big heart entrepreneurship
I I really just as a child finds a toy
in place with it I just played with what
occurred to me and at one point it was
very clear what it is that it is a book
and that is the big heart ventures book
and from the book at the reading events
people were coming to me and saying okay
I want to do it I also want to have
purpose in my life and in my startup and
how do I do it how do I find other
co-founders that think like this and
this is when I decided to start also the
side project the big heart collective is
a community for those people to gather
and to expand its their their own yeah
each other's potential so this is a very
organic process I'm sorry if i
disappoint you but there was no strategy
like saying first I'm gonna do this
do that then I'm gonna do this for me
life is more of a playground and as soon
as you're conscious about what is
happening you can learn really a lot and
you can surprise yourself about the
opportunities why big heart well big big
for me is the big reason you're doing
something the purpose and for me purpose
is never just an ambition just a goal
what you want to have everybody wants to
have something for me big is how the
things that you want to achieve
contribute to a better world
so it's a very mindful very conscious
approach to go setting and you know a
journey heart I I realized do you know
where the word courage comes from it
comes from the latin for color for curve
for heart so courage comes from the
heart and I realized because I have
often very often in my life I have been
claimed to be fearless even Randy
Komisar from kleiner perkins once said
that I'm fearless I was who I was so
humbled especially because it came in a
period where I was really afraid a lot
of red on the inside
but then connecting it where does this
fearlessness come from and I think it
comes from a sense of integrity that I
know what is important for me and I know
how to how to listen to to my intuition
and so this is what big heart stands for
because the purpose in heart is the the
values and I believe that if you're
conscious about both of them so where
you're going and what are you willing to
spend for this what are you not and what
are your boundaries of good and bad then
you can go really far in a venture being
courageous and fearless so that's the
event to the eventual explanation of
what occurred to me just five years ago
without any meaning
yeah so coming forth from our heart is
maybe our like destiny or our divine
purpose on this planet our gifts and so
they're in our soul our spirit or our
essence and then to be able to kind of
like dust off that and bring it forth
into the world it's a it's a tough
process there's a lot of of clearing of
this channel of integrating of trauma of
healing that has to happen in order for
us to come forth with it
so then what was big heart ventures when
you're doing these readings when you
when you're synthesizing putting
together the book what were what are
these key points that you're sharing
with people well all key points are
connected with technology and to
pronounce shape and purpose and the one
key point is that technology has become
so efficient that it is changing its
effect you can see this for example in a
social network there have always been
people with that had broader interests
of the of the mass like the Royals the
politicians the movie stars but suddenly
there was a social network in
democratizing connection the ability to
reach everybody on this planet and this
efficiency transformed the technology
that was built to literally connect
friends on campus to a technology to
build audience for a business so the
efficiency of technology changed its
effect and there are also many other
examples around the financial crisis
there was this a lot of conversations
about automated trading systems before
software emerged and this is why
technology is so really important for
the conversation before software emerged
the job of an investment broker the
stock exchange was to evaluate companies
businesses based on their kpi's but of
course also based on their purpose on
their long term vision on what they
would contribute to society and so on
when algorithms emerged the investment
broker was replaced by software that was
looking for split-second opportunities
sometimes that were entirely optimized
for short-term gains so this entire
purpose thing just fell behind and this
whole thing had the name of the
shareholder value a paradigm he has
gained a lot of criticism during and
after the financial crisis but it's
still the predominantly the predominant
way how companies and businesses around
so first key point is the technology
effective technology changed its effect
second key point is technology has
become so efficient that efficiencies
are given so it's not something we
should care about your LinkedIn profile
right now is an example of automatic of
efficiency so without you being involved
it is out there communicating your
mission vision selling the the the stuff
that we sell and so on the second point
is so that the third point is that given
that efficiency is a given and in the
face of so many challenges like global
warming 7th year in a row The Economist
is reporting highest forced migration
rates in a row we have rising knowledge
gap skill gaps social gaps in the face
of all that and running out of time when
efficiency is given and when technology
has empowered us to achieve so much and
sometimes really so easily why would you
start a company that does no good so
there is this next point that this all
leads to a necessity to leave the
dichotomy thinking between for-profit
and nonprofit businesses behind because
if you can have all efficiency and if
you have so much to solve every business
should be
profitable and social so those are maybe
the the main points around technology
and entrepreneurship and then it's not a
how-to book so you cannot read it and
know how to do everything how to build a
company how to do on purpose but I speak
a lot about courage and I have like a
chapter that's called the seven benefits
of purpose so maybe then the next last
key takeaway from the book is that being
conscious about all that and about
yourself
will really help you go further down the
line of achieving your goals and being
also fearless what is oftentimes the
single one difference between people
that do and don't that's profound I
agree with you completely so what do we
do then when there's this this beautiful
gift that's cooking within all of us
that is like our unique purpose that we
want to bring forth and we have to be
courageous and fearless with bringing it
forth mmm how do we maximize more humans
being able to unleash that well good
question
so I tried maximizing this with one on
one I did a coaching training with the
CTI it's a californian coaching
Institute the biggest in the world and I
started like helping people on a
one-on-one basis and I realized that
this is too slow too you know in effect
full then I told him I should write a
book because it's like 1 to N and then
you can maybe reach other people that
need it and don't have a coach and the
next step in this thinking process was
end to end so everyone can help somebody
everybody has strengths everyone can can
be of use especially in society that is
evolving towards not working for money
super interesting evolution and my
answer will destroy its purpose yes and
absolutely and my my very first stone
laying the underground for this is
Montesa
because it's a peer-to-peer matchmaking
application that helps people help each
other and this is like how how I try to
help how I see this and the second thing
is just a very direct advice when I my
my book readings typically start with
okay who here wants to have an impact
and we are all suckers for impact and
all the hands go up and then if you look
at the stories of people that really had
the impact it was not an overnight
success it was not an easy game it was
not luck it was typically giving away a
lot of power freedom benefits luxury
resources for the for the cause of
something for quite some time people
want to have kids but then they say oh
but it's probably difficult to have kids
well if you want to have an impact you
have to invest something for this and my
piece of advice is if you want to have
an impact you have to find something to
fight for that makes you forget about
the the invest that feels like the
suffering that we go through in order to
which is that feels like a gift to fight
for yes yes so for me for those that
maybe have yet to identify with
something that is of a higher calling
for themselves how do we go about
helping people identify their callings
does meant esse pairing people is that
sort of help people find their callings
more effectively or what can really
catalyze that yeah well for this I have
developed the Hart framework tell us
about it's described in the book so it's
a step by step process because so many
people have processes I'm not the
process person
but it works and it's just an acronym
for a very well-known method from
coaching and from personal development
so H stands for half have all of your
values just write down what you think is
important to you
spirituality for some people it's luxury
for some people its power building stuff
whatever whatever it is have as much as
you can think of written down this is
the H and then there's your values of
your values and values it can be
everything because among us words are
just labels for things that are
different in all of the different heads
so write everything that comes up to
your mind it might be a a sentence it
might be a verb it might be just a
classic value there are also value lists
on the internet where you can download
Oh 200 classified values and write as
many down as you think that refer to you
and then typically around this process
people have several and then comes the e
so elect and this is where it gets
really interesting because yes we I have
a high value on sustainability I have a
high value on productivity I have a high
value on recognition so how do I combine
those three you have to elect what comes
before something else and the order so
you rank yes because they Trump each
other and you might have a great value
on sustainability but if you're not
prepared to repair yourself on five
times before you throw it away you won't
be living up to this value or maybe it's
not so important to you as being cutting
edge in technology which is also fine
and then there is making conscious what
is unconsciously in us because we all
have values we just don't know what they
are and knowing them helps us take
decisions more quickly so the this is
where the
a comes into play so this analyze just
take every word on this piece of paper
that you elected like your shortlist and
think about what does this mean to me
what does sustainability means mean to
me is this like saving the planet by
building a start-up or is it properly
dividing the garbage
is it being a good mom is it whatever so
just analyze what those words stand for
because this is one of the things I
believe are the major cause about losing
track of our consciousness or just of
each other in a society we rely too much
on words that are labels and that are
not the same for everybody yeah and then
it gets really easy so the RS for repeat
for yeah for repeat so you do this
process until you have really little
values we know that the human brain can
only memorize free to maximum 7 values
and if you want to be quickly taking the
decisions that are really truly rightful
for you you have to limit the list so
that you can memorize it so that you're
conscious and then the last step is I
personally find the most effective is
testing values so you can you maybe
you're not sure what what is your most
important value so try it on for a day
go be one day I don't know sustainable
every decision that you take this day
what you eat what you buy how you speak
to people how you advertise your product
how you create new opportunities do
everything prioritizing sustainability
then you will see how you feel because
as I said in the beginning we have the
muscles tool to know if something feels
good around well yeah right or wrong hmm
I like this heart process of yeah I like
a lot of you I know the process guys
I love process and well especially when
we're talking about how to help people
identify what is their most core values
what better way than to in
we just go and start writing down our
core values ranking them and then going
through the process of repeating these
tests analyze them repeating these tests
with them all this type of stuff and
then all of a sudden you have these
maybe three or seven core things that
you carry around with you whereas other
times if we're just walking around we
don't actually carry around with us
those core things and then it's like
other people can program our life rather
than we ourselves choosing where we want
to go and what we want to do and what
value we want to bring to the world and
it's all about just making it bringing
it on the surface because we all have
this it's all in them in an order within
us so we all have like one two three
four five six seven we just don't know
which this is and there is so much noise
around us and so much should have smells
you know the smoke should must all get
to yeah yeah and it's all about it's
lots of noise
yeah just a mechanical bringing it to
the surface and I also believe that you
know your values can change so it's
important to take from time to time the
opportunity to reevaluate what is really
important to you some people do it on
Christmas I don't do it every Sunday I
guess it's also personal thing yeah
oh okay so there's these these are
they're they're within us these core
values and then we have to then go
through a process of identifying what
are those we have to like write them
down and identify them so they're are
they with us from birth or do they
constantly get discovered and changed
throughout life maybe they're different
when you're 50 than when you're 20 yeah
absolutely
values have a lot to do with a lot of
stuff a lot with the prevailing culture
in the country that you live in with the
family that you're raised for with the
relationship that you're having with the
experiences that you're doing
I don't think values are inborn and this
is why it's particularly important to be
conscious about them because it's
something that we have somehow developed
and wouldn't you want to know what you
have in your luggage bringing around you
because every person develops something
else it's something of it's a choice the
values and all that so I don't think
there are built-in there's just so much
that plays a role and exactly for this
purpose it's important to to take a
closer look on that what are your core
values
it's great that you asked when I gave
the TEDx talk in San Francisco last year
in November or in October I delivered
the questions that I thought were most
thought-provoking for people to ask
themselves and others and one of those
questions was what are your core values
Oh since great that that uh that you're
bringing back up right now but it also
may be intimidating because then you're
asking a person to to show what they're
made of it's very intimidating in that
sense yeah but it's also becoming
comfortable with sharing that is really
important yeah I asked it out of
curiosity know thyself yeah one of the
most important principles know thyself
so know thy values yeah yeah yeah that's
true yeah in a in a major understanding
of my values feels as though there's
a deep drive towards a
a future of more connection to our
divine purpose and nature here on the
planet communing more holistically with
source and also unleashing all of our
gifts and helping each other unleash our
gifts so that's one of the core values
and just to figure out how to do that is
it's a big challenge in itself for me
like just figuring out how to maximize
doing that like right now it's like oh
is it is it having more interviews with
leaders is it taking us lower down on
that to focus on a larger synthesis in
distributing multimedia content putting
it together into really like first
principle values in like a book format
or like what are the the ways to most
effectively achieve this and are the
trajectories already determined already
are we already going in what are your
thoughts on that on a free will and
determinism I'm also for the unlimited
opportunities that we can create for
ourselves so I don't have proof for this
other than my own experience but the
other perspective I just don't find the
P link enough which one a perspective of
predetermination yeah I just a boring
game so why do I play this and and also
we might be in the kindergarten as you
said of spirituality but we can look
back to thousands of years of humanity
and centuries and what we see is a
development
towards a better life isn't this like a
justification for for the power of self
for the power to create for the power of
humanity to to create yeah that
definitely seems to be a big part of it
yeah
it just it's like trying to figure out
if everything's happening for the
purpose of you know maximizing meaning
and consciousness and experience and
creativity and technologies helping us
with that process and it's on its exact
perfect path that it's on or if we
diverted away from a holistic
stewardship oriented divine alignment
with source and we're just thinking that
technology is great and that it's
enabling more stuff to happen but the
tree is growing like this crooked
instead of the tree growing yesterday I
agree with you
I just believe this is part of the
process to find out how to do it because
there is nobody knows so how to and
going into this direction going from a
social system to a social system from an
economic system to a next to a next from
a way of living coal living with other
nations on one planet this way or that
way this is just a learning process that
needs to take place for us to learn or
to approach this divine how do you call
it like the the the ultimate state of of
consciousness or yeah I there is there
is no answer on how to do this now and
the only way to change something is to
to act
so we cannot change the world by by
discussions but we have to try different
things on so I agree with you and maybe
we are on the path maybe we're not I
believe it doesn't matter because both
will teach us what to do next
what does those three things that we
were talking about earlier what is kind
of there let's let's list them quick it
was purpose entrepreneurship and was it
innovation technology purpose
entrepreneurship and technology yeah
where do those three things come so I
write my values down I go through this
process of getting to know myself better
and what I want to do in the world and
then how do I like leverage
entrepreneurship and technology to bring
forth my my values a great question
whoo so the thing about technology
becoming exponential so we have the
industry Industrial Revolution going on
it's the revolution that creates
exponential productivity in the first
Industrial Revolution we had created
mechanical productivity so we stopped
producing with our hands and left the
work to machines in the Second
Industrial Revolution we gained
automatic productivity so we or maybe
now let's say how to how to put it it
with the invention of the electricity we
stopped empowering the machines and
gained the the the mass productivity of
having a machine being powered by
electricity then software came and we
gained automatic productivity and now we
are about to gain with artificial
intelligence and exponential
technologies exponential productivity
and there is a very simple Chinese story
that in my opinion illustrates
exponential productivity very good it's
the story about the Chinese man that
invented the game of chess for his king
you know the story No so the King really
loved it and he said oh great I want to
grant you one wish in return as a sign
of thanks what would you want and the
old man was supposedly very wise he said
I only want some grain with grain but I
want it in a specific order
I want one piece of grain to be put on
the first square of the chessboard to on
the second four on the third eight on
the fourth and this makes the
exponential function and on 64 squares
on a square board just on 64 squares
it makes 70.5 quintillion with grains
which is more than all the sand corns on
all the beaches on our planet right now
which is more than the largest wheat
manufacturer China can produce in 6,000
years so this is like really fast really
much and this is what we are gaining now
and I love that your show is called the
simulation because there is a running
gag among techies that in the future it
will be the probability that you are
part of a simulation will be higher than
that you are part of a reality because
there will be still one reality but
exponential number of simulations
creating themselves all the time
so to come back to the question having
this productivity of technology this
really unleashed efficiency in power
technology startups technology
entrepreneurship has become a massive
the most impactful the most powerful way
to change tech companies have a higher
impact on society on the economy on on
the well-being on the people even on the
no level then any public problem has
ever had and then being aligned with
your purpose and with your values as an
entrepreneur happen to believe that the
best way to pursue a goal is therefore
through a technology and to a tech
startup and then what would I do with my
values and wanting to bring them forth
with technology and entrepreneurship
like what would be some of my like first
principled movements towards unleashing
my values yeah um here it gets really
interesting because most entrepreneurs
want to have an impact and want to
create change and they start the
majority of us start by truly purely by
good intentions we all want to save the
world and everybody wants to have their
share and contribute but if you're not
clear about the values you will soon
face resistance because what is impact
impact is you push and then the third
role of mechanics is you get pushed back
so if you're really about to have an
impact
you're going to face resistance and the
story of resistance almost always goes
like this first you are a good person
then you want to have an impact then you
start having impact and then you're
faced resistance and you're threatened
to lose something that you like and if
you're not conscious about why you're
doing the things that you do and what is
like how is that contributing to a
larger world you will not do a lot of
wrong if you say oh no I just changed my
direction and this this little
inflection point when you are taking the
right or the wrong decision concept
consciously is not something really big
it's not a strategy that you create with
a big team and you paint on the wall
it's something that you do all day long
every day with every conversation that
we have with every littlest decision
that you have and
to unleash your potential to a tech
startup I believe it's very important
today when with technology you can have
a massive and rapid impact on the other
end of the planet within days about what
you really want to achieve and really
focus on that as on a lighthouse because
otherwise what we what we've seen a lot
in the past 15 years since I have been
in this field and also since tech
startups have been around because they
have always been they have only been
around since the internet so in the past
30 years and then a few do merge so it's
not it has this tech entrepreneurship
Inc has only been around for 20 30 years
and dogma and frameworks have only
emerged in the past 15 so it's a very
very fresh thing too so if you want to
really be impactful you should be able
to resist resistance and you do it with
courage and courage comes from your
values and from knowing what you're
doing it for from the purpose and it's
something about day to day decisions
little little little steps what we've
seen is to finish my thoughts a lot of
startup starts with a purpose to solve
some problem and then they run out of
money and then they say okay we need to
fundraise and then the investors come
and suddenly solving the customers
problem is something yeah on the site
next to the first purpose returning the
investors their money and is totally
shifts your focus so one one thing is
really to to be mindful about those
choices because nobody has said you need
an investment or you need a lot of
customers so you need a big company or
you need whatever you have the freedom
to decide to do just the right things
but it requires the courage to
look at the look at an open end road
rather than I want to be famous within 5
years to come to forest 30 young of 30
or whatever yeah yeah that's really
critical advice so we're initially going
to face a lot of resistance when we take
our values and we want to push them
forth with entrepreneurship and
technology even when we do successfully
maybe get through the first couple steps
there's going to be even more resistance
on the next couple steps and you're just
gonna keep facing resistance as you keep
going and so to persevere through that
with great amounts of courage is
important also to be patient so that
it's not about some sort of like I want
to get super high super fast but that
it's more about just I want to provide
value to other people at whatever pace I
am aligned with the divine purpose to
bring yeah and then there is no failure
because if you are on purpose if you're
driven by the desire to create a better
world you create it with every single
one of those efforts with every single
one of those little inflection points
overcoming resistance you create a
better world by every conversation that
we have by every check that you pay or
get it is failure by definition
disappears and a lot of the talk about
failure is because we define a very
narrow very egocentric goal like I want
to have those things by this moment and
of course this is something that can
fail but the purpose can never fail and
I actually start my book with with the
mission of the Chinese aerospace team
that reached the dark side of the moon
at the beginning of this year and it's a
really really important deaf deaf
definition and the lining thing so they
had the purpose to reach the dark side
of the Moon which was not yet
reached by humanity because it's on the
other side it's difficult to reach and
not accessible for our satellites and
the purpose of the mission was to reach
this site now the purpose of the mission
was to reach this side so that we can
learn about the dark side of the Moon
and by this about the entire moon and by
this about the entire universe and by
this of our our own place in it better
so this is the purpose their mission was
successful they landed on the dark side
of the moon but even if they hadn't
landed the purpose wouldn't have failed
because the purpose is to learn about
all the stuff so I think what really
purpose gives you is the freedom of
failure and the freedom for courage and
this is why it is so profound ooh I like
that okay so you're free from failure
and you're more free to be more
courageous and to persevere and to be
driven by purpose rather than be driven
by any materialism or fame or yeah yeah
yeah I heard the talk by simon Sinek
it's from a new book he's working on
it's called the infinite game and he
says a lot of what we do in society and
business in particular we play as a
finit game and the finit game is defined
by its predefined it has a beginning and
an ending and you know all the rules and
all the players from the beginning but
the world is not like this you almost
never know the rules you almost never
know the players and there is actually
no ending so if you play the infinite
game focus on purpose and on what I
really want to contribute you're just
laying the stones and maybe you will not
be the one that reaches to the end of
the road but you're laying the stones
for others to come and eventually reach
this point and this is why I know no
large social
has been driven by one person most of
them have been a series of small events
destinies of individuals that were
needed in order for this one moment for
this one flagship event notorious
journalistically represented thing to
happen so that the entire system changes
yeah that's great it's a great way to
put it as that if you follow that your
purpose that it's your laying down the
the stepping stones and that you're the
goal isn't to finish paving the path the
goal is to just keep laying down
stepping stones for more people to be
able to bring their gifts forth must
build a more better world yeah just
think about the book because I know
you're working on something too and I
have recently published a big heart
ventures and I did a little bit of
research being an author being a writer
in Germany is the second most desired
profession and German is a country with
88 million citizens do you know how many
full-time registered authors writers
live in Germany around 8,000 Wow so
being it the second most desired
profession and having that little
writers in such a big country that is
also wealthy so it's not just a matter
of can I earn with this or not it's just
there is a lot of fear so people who
write books typically very often do not
publish them out of the fear will it be
successful will it be recognized sir
yeah so now if you if you think about
the purpose of the book and this is how
I wrote my book if you do this but if
the book is Purpose Driven and my
purpose was to start this conversation
about the influence that technology can
have and our responsible role as
entrepreneurs in it better like
yeah then you are achieving this
I am already living the purpose of
having this topic being the conversation
without having the need to sell the book
or the book to be successful or to to
become a successful writer because this
book is not about me it is about this
topic and no matter if it's well-written
or poorly or whatever it is already
creating or co-creating this movement
towards purpose sustainability away from
shareholders value another so it's just
one of the pieces that are also
necessary to to sum when reach the
critical mass and change the way we we
do business yeah so when we move from a
place of selflessness when we move from
a place of purpose of a divine
co-creation of knowing that we may just
be putting down some of the foundational
stuffs for others to walk down it just
makes it so that our contribution to
society feels more whole every step of
the way and it doesn't feel like we're
ever lacking some sort of I'm lacking
resources or I'm lacking some sort of
like a shareholder return or all these
other types of things hmm but we still
need our basic needs met so that that
kind of makes it also a little bit
complicated because we do need like
investing so much time into something we
want to have our basic needs be met yeah
so that we can continue being creative
yes but I have never said self the
selfishness selfishness
yes opposite selflessness no it is not
about and this is see this is the
problem right now we think either you
are there for the profit or you have to
be selfless so it's like money or love I
don't believe this technology has
empowered us to be both and I don't
think in
extremes I believe that if we want to
become better we need to be looking for
ways to do both so it's really it's
definitely not this selfless game
because this is something that is eating
you up and is actually making the impact
less there is a lot of evidence for this
for example how our healed health system
works
so job social jobs that are known to be
done by people that are proposed driven
that do them not for the money but
because they want to help typically are
worse paid typically people in those
professions need to retire earlier
because they're burned out and we know
that this has not contributed to a high
quality of service in this area so it
has to be a there has to be an
equilibrium what I'm saying is that when
you're trying to do a business try not
to do it to become famous which startups
are known for our founders try not to do
it to become rich which very few
successful companies are known for try
not to do it to to be cool because
entrepreneurship is not a cool game it's
actually very often a very mundane set
of activities that need to be done and
if you're not doing it for any of those
reasons but you're doing to really solve
a problem or to really help somebody or
to really help the whole humanity make
one step in one direction then you're
going to be successful by definition
yeah yeah I love the amount of time that
you've passed on figuring out this being
able to communicate to other people and
inspire them thanks to you know yeah
thanks for doing this thank you I like
this a lot is some mint s is available
for people to also download and use and
the big heart venture is available for
people to buy and read and share yes
Simon Tessa cannot be downloaded it's a
web app you can try it on a website the
book is available on Amazon or in every
large bookshop in Germany there is
nothing else I sell maybe maybe the big
heart collective so if you if people
want to join and meet other Purpose
Driven entrepreneurs or want to preneur
the the community is available and the
big heart collective calm and there is
not much more I have a couple other
questions that we asked her yes that I
want to ask you okay what is your
relationship with God or source or the
divine or creation what's your
relationship with that I told you my
opinion about words being labels for
stuff so I am I'm always very cautious
when people misuse a label not with its
purpose to make a shortcut to something
on the inside but dogmatically so for me
all of that is like the same there is
there is the the conscious connection to
yourself or it's lack and there is the
power to believe in something better or
there is not so this is how I see those
all those labels words you know what I
mean so your relationship with those
words is that the words take away from
the your connection to it or what is
your you yes this is a good point I
haven't thought about this yes but yes I
feel the words are superfluous this is
right right yeah yeah
so it's I think one one of the reasons
for for religion to be where it is is
that it started relying a lot way too
much on words and maybe way too little
on the purpose of those things so be it
the one the one religion or the other or
just the believe in yourself
those are all words that are different
for every person
and our own unique ways of communing
with that higher power is so important
and I just feel like it's there's a
great amount of lacking in our world of
like I just do feel like humans have
forgotten that higher power in many ways
and that maybe technology can help us
remember that higher power
it does definitely feel sometimes like
yeah like really fast computers or like
really fast internet on the one hand
side we have automated ourselves a lot
don't yet we have gained a lot of free
time and people are starting to meditate
again and we have evidence from really
spiritual societies from thousands of
years before so I don't necessarily
believe it's a downward trend maybe it's
like a cyclic development and I do
believe that all of what is happening is
it needs to be so that the next the
future comes what would you say about
the spirit or the soul meeting the body
for this adventure of consciousness or
do you feel like consciousness emerges
from the biological yeah absolutely and
there is um so again consciousness
emerges biologically are words labels
but I do believe that each and every one
of us has failed it sometimes somebody
says a word and suddenly we feel it
somehow and for a long time this has
been an esoteric subject but with
technology again with computer
tomography and so on a lot of advances
in neuroscience have been made showing
the connection between the mind in the
body and depending on in what regards
you consider spirituality being part of
the mind
or a mind characteristic ax it has been
proven so to say that what people
assumed thousands of years so far is
true do you feel like we come from
somewhere beyond this body mm-hmm into
the body for experience yeah I haven't I
haven't thought about it
I haven't maybe I'm not on my journey
there yet to think about those subjects
but I am very much a fan of being
hearing now you know so I love thinking
about stuff and every person who wants
to write a book needs to be a little bit
of you know philosopher too - right
spinning tops and - like spinning
thoughts but I am more concerned about
really this consciousness of now what is
now available what is now possible what
is the next step and the only thing that
really next to this matters for me is
the great purpose that I want to spare
my time for do you feel like our
disconnection from nature from source do
you feel like that's the reason why we
have so many of the problems in our
world I don't know
actually sitting here and looking out of
your window I feel you're very connected
to nature so California is a beautiful
place where it feels like at least from
the outside it feels very much it seems
very much like people are living very
close to nature also in Bulgaria so I
don't know yeah when you're not in like
the downtown LA or downtown San
Francisco or Oakland etc when you're
more like near the woods or near the
ocean or whatnot you're definitely more
holistically yeah and I'm sure in
Bulgaria and other places in the world
as well that when you if you're in the
metropolis the downtown city center it
feels like the matrix when you're
outside near the woods and whatnot it
feels less so yeah like that would you
say that we're in a simulation a good
one why would you want to know what
difference would it make
understanding our source code is very
important so if we understand our source
code then maybe we understand the
ultimate nature of this reality mm-hmm
and that makes it easier for us to
potentially solve some of the big
problems and big challenges stuff yeah
yeah and on the other hand side if you
if you describe if you explain a
three-year-old how how a car is built or
a solar panel he would soon or she would
still not be able to build it because
they would lack for example the physical
strength to bring up the tools and you
know so it's it's always the right time
with the right resources with the right
purpose that need to come together for
something to emerge
yeah yeah what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world
children's eyes yeah just the ingenuity
and the curiosity and and and and how to
say uncolored nests of emotion the
ability to to witness something without
the judgment absorbed by the desire just
to witness it not even consciously to
learn because we grown-ups are like okay
let me witness it so I improve so I get
better there I just a witness yes I just
think there is nothing more beautiful
than this I love it this is such a fun
conversation for me too thank you for
inviting me I'm so happy you came on
thank you thank you for joining us on
the show thanks a lot and good luck with
your book and with your project thank
you thank you and likewise same thing
with you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments
blonde you're on the episode let us know
what you think and also do have more
conversations to your friends your
families co-workers people online about
purpose about your values about how to
unleash those values into the world
leveraging technology leveraging
entrepreneurship to bring those forth
also check out the links in the Bible
Ottoman test.com also Tina Russa Hakam
big heart book comm check out our social
profiles as well check those out
everyone support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
organizations around the world that you
believe and supports simulation our
links are below to our patreon
crypto-currency paypal links find all
those below you can design cool merch
and get paid also go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon